so then they're like well [ __ ] you want
to do red rocks and i was like what's
ten thousand seats and they're like yeah
you can sell it i was like but then
let's just come up with a video
so then [ __ ] red rocks i go i'm like
panicking right i don't know the video
i've sold like 5 000 tickets like two
months out and i and i do my movie and i
blow out my my thing so i go
what did you do you hurt your what yeah
i i did a movie and i ripped all my
tendons off my arm so i had to go in for
surgery and i go
i'm talking to cardiologist night before
surgery and he goes so
i said is there anything he goes do any
music you want to go under to i go i can
go under he goes it should be fun man i
said i'll tell you what can i not count
backwards from 100 can i just have my
cell phone i'm going to promote my red
rock show and then you put me under as i
as the thing
and then so pert type in bert red rocks
and then that this is you going into
real surgery going into real surgery uh
i don't know where you'll find it you
might might
i'm going into surgery right now
i just
we're playing pretty skill for a revival
perfect way to go under i have a great
team around me
i have a great team around me we're all
gonna go to jail now but what i want to
tell you for real
while i lay here on this gurney and
panic
is red rocks september 8th i will be
performing at red rocks okay your
tickets at burperberg.com
jimmy buffett's there the night before
the night after i can't wait to do red
rocks i have invited my anesthesiologist
i love you guys god bless i'll see you
on the other side
so you if i go into surgery and i just
grab my phone and i do one take and my
nerve block falls in and my arm
collapses and i go [ __ ] so i grab it
with the other thing and now he's got me
in they're rolling me in and i was like
as i'm laying here on this bed about to
go under go under anesthesia and go into
surgery i'm nervous i'm scared there's
one thing i want to tell you red rocks
september 9th i will be performing there
the night before and after jimmy buffett
my anesthesiologist goes i love jimmy
buffett and i go you want to come and
he's like i'd love to come he's ah yeah
great and then he puts me under the
phone falls
and then i posted it sold out red rocks
it's like all you needed to do your life
is a promo
[Music]